he came into my room
he said tomorrow morning i'm taking you
to see a doctor in central london to do
a test on you
i asked him what kind of test
the test was to see if zara was still a
virgin
he told me sit on the couch and open
both my legs
it was a two finger test obviously i was
a virgin
i was quite traumatized uncomfortable
it was somebody you didn't know
it felt like like you're not a human
being anymore
you wouldn't treat an animal like that
he could see i was terrified i was
tearful
crying i pleaded with him i begged him
don't do it but there is no law to
protect
girls and women like zara a british-born
bangladeshi
ahead of her forced marriage the groom's
family demanded to know
if zara was still a virgin
where girls are found not to be virgins
clinics can offer a
form of hymen repair surgery so the girl
still bleeds
during intercourse campaigners say these
clinics
are profiting by exploiting vulnerable
women
we are seeing an escalation in girls
coming forward
begging for help anita prem has
campaigned
for years to have this practice banned
we are demanding that virginity testing
and so-called hyman repair
is made a criminal offence it has to be
girls that are forced to have a
virginity test view it as sexual abuse
view it as a violation
this is a racket
london's harley street is synonymous
with medical excellence
and here there are doctors offering
hymenoplasty
the number of girls that are presenting
for aminoplasties
is rising and these are
due to fact that their lives may even be
at risk
dr dhiraj bahr is one of them he told me
he doesn't perform virginity tests but
does
offer hymenoplasty at his clinic but
only
if he is certain that his patients are
seeing him
because they want to a lot of these
these women who come usually have
issues with with their families in terms
of where they have to be virgins when
they get married you know the big
streets have to
have to have blood blood stained on them
and many of them
due to their normal lives uh usually
have gone through some form of physical
trauma
which has resulted in the hymen being
ruptured i think
by providing this service we open the
doors to women who
want to seek this treatment and give
them an option
i mean it's not up to me or anybody else
or the or the government to decide
whether we should take away this option
away from people you're saying you offer
this service to protect
women yes because i fear that if
people do not offer this service then
many women who
are seeking this service will eventually
go to scrupulous individuals behind
you know back alleys or fly across to
other countries to get these procedures
done
and i think over here in the uk we have
we we have a proper framework
a medical and legal framework which
protects patients
but on the same street as dr barr's
clinic there are surgeons
who stand opposed to the practice it's
unnecessary procedures it is actually we
are violating
somebody's uh a very intimate part
for no good reason dr ashfaq khan
refuses
to carry out virginity tests or
hymenoplasty
and he's faced a backlash for speaking
out
against the practice i think that at
this point
the discussion was mainly is immorally
or ethically correct or not
i think this is the time we should
actually make it legally
banned simply because this procedure
is not necessary we are dealing with
because we are supporting
a a concept that woman has to be
virgined before
waiting and and the procedure and the
certificate the whole
idea is it's so um
i would say it disrespectful for the
woman
the world health organization wants a
ban on all forms of virginity testing
the royal college of midwives says it is
indefensible with no medical benefit
but a quick internet search will find
many clinics
offering to perform hymenoplasty
it's the language used around the
procedure that's
really questionable the clinics use
words or phrases
like re-virgination or virginity
restoration one site
even says the procedure helps you to get
your virginity back this advert for the
regency international clinic makes a
direct link
between women being killed because of
doubts
surrounding their virginity and hymen
repair
and this advert for the belvedere clinic
talks about
marriages being annulled if a hymen is
not
intact we approached
both clinics the belvedere told us it
did not offer hymen repair
and would take immediate action to
correct any advertising on its site
the regency clinic did not respond
paisey mahmoud was just 16 when she was
coerced into marrying a man
twice her age here in the uk she says
there is
a clear link between virginity testing
child marriage
and other forms of gender-based violence
it can definitely lead to
a fatal incident where they actually
lose their lives based on this
fail test i think it's about removing
this cultural lens and barrier and it's
about recognizing this as a form of
violence towards women and girls
and it's about educating on what
virginity means and the fact that
not having an intact hymen does not mean
that you you are not a virgin and
therefore does not mean you don't have
value it's really about educating young
people
and also communities who believe in
virginity as such a high value
peso's sister benaz was murdered by
their own father
after she escaped a violent forced
marriage
she was said to have dishonored her
family both she
and paisey had to undergo virginity
tests
we understand the government is
considering legislation to ban virginity
testing
it'll come too late for zara she is now
estranged
from her family and trying to rebuild
her life
the test has destroyed me i can't think
of getting married
i don't want to have children i don't
want to be in a relationship at all
i've lost all my happiness
ashish josh is sky news